could southern Africa be part of the
solution to Germany's energy woes that
is the hope of economy Minister Robert
habbeck as he visits two countries in
the region both of which are looking
toward green hydrogen production Mr
habeg was in Namibia on Monday to
support a 10 billion dollar hydrogen
project from a German firm today he
landed in South Africa the war in
Ukraine and the resulting loss of
Russian natural gas Imports has sent
havoc and the German government
scrambling for alternatives
well we talk more about Germany's
interest in southern Africa in just a
moment first let's take a look at why
green hydrogen is such a focal point
the most abundant element in the
universe hydrogen is playing an
increasingly prominent role in the race
to ensure a successful transition to
Greener energy
the most common form of hydrogen as an
energy source today is gray hydrogen
but it's not really a clean alternative
as it produces tons of carbon dioxide
during the production process
then there is blue hydrogen some
scientists say this causes more
pollution than burning coal because it
requires huge amounts of natural gas to
produce
the only form of hydrogen that makes any
real sense in terms of reducing our
carbon footprint is green
hydrogen is created using electricity
from renewable sources to split hydrogen
from water
you have to make sure that that hydrogen
is actually being produced through an
electrolyzer that's operating on 100
green renewable energy
right now it's not possible to make
enough green hydrogen electricity to
replace fossil fuels environmental
activists say coordinated strategies
need to be put in place by industrial
leaders and decision makers to scale up
Technologies and bring production costs
down so that green hydrogen can be
produced economically and securely
alright let's get more on this from DW
southern Africa correspondent Adrian
krisha Adrian why does the German
government feel that Namibia is the
preferred spot when it comes to creating
green hydrogen
of course Namibia is a huge country with
very few people only 2.5 million people
there's a lot of sand there's a lot of
sun there's a lot of wind and there's
the ocean next door so the conditions
are perfect for such a project but we
have to recall this is still very early
stages the minister signed a memorandum
of understanding a number of 10 billion
euros was cohorted people were talking
about this kind of amount that needs to
be invested before a project can
kick-start it could only start around
2025 the construction and only in 2027
that's where they talk about possible
experts could happen for Germany for
example so some people are rather
skeptical and rather reluctant to push
it in the dimensions that the government
tries to because of course they also
have other massive projects in Africa in
mind that didn't really materialize
remember 10 15 years ago we talked about
a massive solar project in the Sahara
Desert there was talks for years about a
gas pipeline from Nigeria to Northern
Africa that hasn't happened up until now
so some people are skeptical others say
this could be a break through if this
project really happens
now talk to you about what Minister
harbek said a quite a specific or quite
interesting quote here during this visit
he said the last thing we should accept
is some kind of green energy imperialism
now he's referring to the time between
1884 and 1915 when the German Empire was
an often brutal colonial power in which
was then German Southwest Africa so what
does he mean specifically when he says
when he says he wants to prevent uh some
sort of colonialism here
I mean two points I think one yes you're
right is the colonial past of Germany
and keeping in mind that there are still
negotiations ongoing between the two
governments about a possible reparations
deal but the second and I think the more
important part at this stage for the
minister is the point that Germany and
other countries should not come to
Namibia trying to find sources of energy
and just take them away from there
remember Namibia and a lot of African
countries desperately need energy they
need electricity on their own there's a
lot of countries here that has massive
electricity problems Tanzania Zimbabwe
South Africa where we are at the moment
where you have hours of load shedding
meaning no power a day for most of the
citizens here just because the system
does not have enough energy and
electricity and also in Namibia as we
speak is importing most of its
electricity so first of all it shouldn't
be the idea of bringing only electricity
to Europe it also has to be the idea of
creating a income generation and source
of electricity in these countries
themselves
DW southern Africa correspondent Adrian
karish Adrian thank you